bon à faire une interview vous avez des
nouvelles est ce que il regrette
toujours le temps béni des colonies le
tablier les colonies non je pense pas me
l'a jamais regretté un c'est un petit il
joue un personnage dans cette chanson
ouais c'est pas est ce que quand il
chante je suis pourri pense aux strings
pour homme est un grand homme je pense
pas est ce qui fait toujours l'amour en
chantant toujours des soirées de son
statut faire mais si munich / e s qui
sont hors jeu toujours la gueule dans
les bals populaires ou bien et préfère
saint tropez maintenant à n'auriez plus
belles populaire à saint tropez pas trop
tu veux toujours pas qu'on l'appelle
france il aime toujours les ricains nom
de moins en moins ouais ouais il a été
il n'était pas trop bon ça c'est une
longue histoire mais non validées
américains pour ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont fait tout le monde complètement pour
dire tout mélanger mais sur le sur le
final et d'ailleurs il n'y va plus ils
allaient tout le temps aux états unis
il habite toujours en france
suffisamment la france beaucoup mieux
que ce qu'on dit non ti boucan corsa il
ce corps 6 beaucoup ça doit être l'âge
est ce que le vix pense au sida quand il
dit elle court elle court la maladie
d'amour il n'y pensait pas à l'époque en
tout cas cela n'était pas d'actualité
pensée qui viendra un jour dans cette
émission j'ai des doutes quand même ah
oui oui c'est pas je pense pas qu'il
sera à l'aise en ce jour de retour mais
bon je vais pas répondre à sa place mais
je pense pas que c'est pas trop pas trop
son truc vous intéresse vous ça va ça va
je suis fatigué met à l'aise
bordeaux
mission